одна з перших завгодно поспішаючи футболок у
нас було з виходу ним нам та слоганом
київ big вела kyuubi quello che
[оплески]
якусь підйомну
підйом і віч його імам али води час ми
реально розуміємо ці проблеми рублі
оцінюємо тип оцінювати і проблеми та
кисну етики чи треба будуть розвивати якщо
у нашій Україні у вашій країні тому
там розум з подіваем відчуваєш як ще з
зміниться на крачок і щось зміниться до
кращому просто просто треба розуміти що
це можливо нарик не 2 рукою два роки
ганчірочок від цього просила ти 510 руки в 10
[оплески]
[музика]
дуже багато було стріляти дуже багато
була стара ти пив у нас показував з
росії за дитячою спілкою ментальність
ментальністю покоління ще скажемо і так
радянське
зараз це стріляти чи не тестують і
пара збуваються і відкриваєте створ тег
основа історія створюється нова історія та
знову живуть з навушники може робот дуже
багато для того, щоб створити але в
україну
створити нову країну
[музика]
у
блог
ось
[музика]